so this is the fourth episode on how to
get your shots uh more filmic
okay so this is uh the picture we'll be
working on
super easy at it as you can see no
problem
let's make a new variant by pressing f7
let's go in the details tab
sharpening all the way down details all
the way down luminance down because it
was shot at iso
320
so it was shot
because it was shot at a really low iso
we won't be needing single pixel
cool
um in the exposure tab bring the
brightness all the way up
uh exposure
just a little bit up
like so cool
contrast maybe now i'll leave the
contrast or no
contrast just
at
-29 or something like that
let's
let's crush the whites
let's uh
push the blacks a little bit yeah
and then go in in the rgb
bring up the blacks
okay
bring the shadows a little bit up
and bring the whites down so we're
crushing the details right here okay not
not that much but we're crushing a
little bit the details in his face as
you can see
there's not so much contrast anymore
and by by doing so we're making the
image look softer just like film
i'm going to add a little bit of
vignetting because i want to get rid of
all the details around the subject i
want to focus on him
so let's change the method on circular
and
add a little bit something like that
maybe too much blacks crushing
good maybe
saturation all the way up because i want
to make this look golden
more shadows
okay
okay good
in the color balance tab let's um
add more orange
in the mid tones and uh some blue and
the shadows the blue actually the cyan
is going to be more towards the green
because that's how i like it
okay cool something like that
uh i'm gonna go in
to
in the color editor
and in the last square i'm gonna
slide a hue
to the left making it you know making it
more red then it's green
good something like that
maybe i'll add a little bit more
saturation
let's see
can we have a little bit just yeah good
because as you can see there was
that that's my shadow i want to get rid
of the shadow
something like that
so here you have it this is it this is
the final result i want to add just a
little bit more grain because this was
super super clean as you can see
there's absolutely no no grain to it
being shot at such low iso
and i'll add some silver rich grain
which absolutely looks gorgeous i love
it maybe more
more powerful impact would be nice just
like that cool
so don't forget the next episode is the
last one uh from the series and you'll
be able to download all the film presets
for free for your own uh personal
projects or commercial projects no
problem
you can also find me on social media
if you're interested to see my latest
projects and i hope to see you next time